on
[Musique]
notre planète était dans un très vite
trois fois par an nous avions coutume de
rendre à la terre que la mère n'avait
offert
nous avons vécu ainsi en harmonie avec
les éléments
pendant des siècles et des siècles
jusqu'à ce que survienne l'avocat lee
lahore coulera si cologna repart bien
mieux vaut tard que pas du tout agent
valérian et laureline
nous avons besoin de vous sur la station
alpha pour une délicate mission
le centre d'alpha et irrespirable et
l'air y est hautement contaminée et ça
continue de progresser comme une tumeur
une tumeur on peut décrire
[Musique]
ce qui les a attaqués
l'art
qui auraient des raisons de détruire
alpha la majorité des espèces ou presque
y est présent c'est une arme de
destruction massive et derrière chaque
arme il ya un tueur peu importe peu
qu'il s'agit agents valérian et
laureline vous avez moins de six heures
pour localiser la menace
gérant de l'éliminer berlin suivez mon
q pourquoi vous attaquez parce que quand
tu as vu ce qu'on cherche
c'est notre mission qui n'a pas de sens
général quelqu'un nous ment
et pan depuis
[Musique]
je n'ai rien
notre destinée est entre vos mains
[Musique]